[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend ihnen allen der g7-gipfel ist zu
Ende und er kommt an einer Wahrheit
nicht vorbei diese Welt ist deutlich
zersplitterter und komplizierter
geworden früher haben die großen
Industrienationen ihre
schlusserklärungen verabschiedet und
sind ganz selbstverständlich davon
ausgegangen die würden schon weltweit
Wirkung erzielen vorbei nicht mal der
Krieg gegen die Ukraine führt zu einer
gemeinsamen Haltung wirklich rund um den
Globus die einen fragen was das mit
ihnen zu tun habe die anderen freuen
sich über ganz neue Geschäfte mit
Russland
wir stehen auf der richtigen Seite der
Geschichte mit unserem Einsatz für
Demokratie und gegen russlandsaggression
aber es sieht allmählich ein bisschen
einsam aus auf der richtigen Seite der
Geschichte meint der frühere
US-Finanzminister Larry Summers selbst
wäre das ein bisschen arg pessimistisch
findet muss zugeben diese Welt hat jetzt
viele Pole und wir werden uns auf alle
davon einstellen müssen Andreas kühnerst
wenn Olaf Scholz jetzt vier Schritte
weitergeht ist er in Nordkorea aber der
Kanzler und seine Frau Britta Ernst
halten auf dem allerletzten Stück
Südkorea an in panmund JOM an einer der
schlimmsten undurchdringlichsten Grenzen
der Welt kommt ein Bild zustande mit dem
das kanzlerpaar nach drei Tagen die
sieben Gipfel daran erinnern will dass
die Abwesenheit von Krieg nicht
automatisch Frieden ist
aber auch an das was uns eben als
Geschichte gemeinsam bewegt nämlich eine
Teilung die wir mittlerweile überwunden
haben die hier aber nicht überwunden ist
das China den G7 ausgerechnet Teilung
vorwirft ausgerechnet heute hätte
vielleicht ausgerechnet hier eine
Erwiderung verdient das Staatsfernsehen
liest
pekingsgipfelreaktion vor die G7
behaupten hochtrabend eine stabile
weltfördern zu wollen aber sie behindern
den Frieden und die Entwicklung anderer
Länder
dabei sollte gerade dieser Gipfel die
Staaten die die Ukraine unterstützen mit
denen die es nicht tun versöhnen der
Handschlag von Präsident selenski und
Indiens premiermodi kommt zustande der
Handschlag mit Brasiliens Präsident Lula
nicht
ob sie Lenski enttäuscht ist
ich finde er sollte enttäuscht sein
Deutschland die Europäer und auch
Gastgeber Japan verhindern auf diesem
Gipfel ein generelles Exportverbot nach
Russland wie es US-Präsident beiden gern
beschlossen hätte nun schärft jedes Land
einzeln nach nicht nur aber auch gegen
China
wir haben Sanktionen verhängt und wir
wollen dass die nicht umgangen werden
und genau das ist das worauf wir auch
bestehen müssen übrigens gilt das auch
im Hinblick auf Waffenlieferung und
diese Botschaft ist sehr klar ist sie
überhaupt verstanden worden von vielen
Ländern in der Welt dass der
ukraineische Präsident mit einer Gruppe
seiner engsten Vertrauten seit fast
einem Monat von Staat zu Staat und von
Staatschef zu Staatschef eilt ist auch
eine Botschaft an den russischen es gibt
ein stetig wachsendes Interesse es gibt
mehr und mehr hilfs zu sagen und es gibt
keinen Haftbefehl
aber die Gräueltaten des Krieges
verfolgen selenski wo immer er ist ein
Reporter fragt ist bachmut gefallen
genau ich glaube nicht da ist aber auch
nichts mehr die Russen haben alles
zerstört es gibt keine Häuser mehr es
ist eine Tragödie bachmut gibt es nur
noch in unseren Herzen
dann legt wolotti mir selensky am
Friedensdenkmal in Hiroshima einen
Blumenstrauß nieder es hätte ein Bild
mit allen Anwesenden auch den noch
skeptischen staatslenkern geben sollen
aber das kam auf diesem Gipfel nicht
zustande
wir haben den Kanzler gehört gerade
jetzt hören wir eine außenpolitische
Stimme der Oppositionen Norbert Röttgen
von der CDU hat den schönen guten Abend
einen guten Abend wann hat es das
zuletzt gegeben ein Präsident im Krieg
der sein Land verlässt um die halbe Welt
fliegt oder eigentlich um die ganze Welt
fliegt ehrlich gesagt um für seine Sache
zu werben aus ihrer Sicht wie
erfolgreich kann das sein
also das letzte Mal hat es das gegeben
als Winston Churchill um die Welt
gereist ist vor allen Dingen auch nach
Amerika um den Beitritt zu
erbitten und der ist dann spät gekommen
ist Zeit wir sind in einer historischen
Zensur und wir haben den Krieg zurück in
Europa und das oberste Ziel ist den
Krieg wieder zu verbannen aus Europa und
insofern war das ein Gipfel der
Geschlossenheit und der Einheit und
darum wirkungsvoll ja von von einem Teil
der Staatenlenker die dort waren ist
aber auch wieder klar geworden dass es
eben Staaten gibt die die Hälfte der
Weltbevölkerung repräsentieren die
denken nicht daran Russland zu
verurteilen müssen wir uns damit am Ende
abfinden
nein wir müssen uns damit nicht abfinden
und es war darum ja auch klug andere
Länder und deren Präsidenten einzuladen
also aus Indien Brasilien Indonesien
fast 300 Millionen Einwohner und andere
Vietnam andere sind gekommen und das war
sehr gut und auch einen Lernfortschritt
dass die G7 also die großen westlichen
Demokratie westlich im Sinne der Normen
also Japan weil es ja gehört ja auch
dazu
ausgreifen und sagen wir sind uns nicht
genug alleine wir müssen die Welt
überzeugen von den Prinzipien die wir
ähm die wir einklagen und einfordern
nämlich die Prinzipien der unkrater und
das war ein erster Erfolg wo die hat
gesprochen und hat sich dem nicht
entzogen ja momentan hat gesprochen
sagen sie aber Mutti hat auch gesagt wir
machen das was für uns Inneren und in
der gut ist und wo die kauft fleißig
russisches Öl aktuell denn sein
Argumentation geht ja irgendwie so warum
sollen Menschen bei uns in Indien leiden
wenn viele hunderte tausend Kilometer
entfernt in der Ukraine kriegt tobt
ja und das müssen wir auch zuerst mal
verstehen erstens weil wir Europäer uns
gegenüber den Konflikten in der Welt
auch nicht sehr viel anders verhalten in
der Unabhängigkeit von Südsudan sind
400.000 Menschen gestorben ich glaube
nicht dass wir damals sehr große Notiz
in Kämpfen im Bürgerkriegen Notiz davon
genommen haben man muss auch die
Interessenlage sehen
indien hat wirtschaftliche Ambitionen
macht für sich das beste nutzt billiges
russisches Öl Indien bekommt Waffen von
Russland also es gibt Abhängigkeiten die
diese Länder nicht einfach so
abschütteln weil wir jetzt in Europa
einen Krieg und ein Problem haben was
auch heißt dass wir unser eigenes
Problem auch selber im Wesentlichen
lösen müssen aber wir müssen den die
anderen in der Welt vor allen Dingen die
unsere Prinzipien teilen weil sie
Demokratien sind wie Indien die
Indonesien für die Sache der Demokratie
der Freiheiten des Friedens gewinnen und
das ist versucht und das war ein erster
Schritt ja das das ist ja zum Beispiel
auch die Idee des Bundeskanzlers aktuell
den globalen Süden mit einbinden und
zwar wie er immer sagt auf Augenhöhe ich
nehme an das ist etwas was Sie begrüßen
bei Olaf Scholz oder ja das macht er er
hat das ja auch als Deutschland ihr G7
Präsidentschaft hatte gemacht hat das
glaube ich wirklich auch initiiert diese
Ausweitung und er macht es seither
weiter ob das Afrika ist ob das Asien
ist und das ist sehr gut sehr notwendig
dass begrüße ich unterstützt sich sehr
seine richtige Außenpolitik in diesem
Teil die Frage ist nur wie funktioniert
das ganz genau und wie kriegt man dann
Erfolge raus auf der anderen Seite sieht
man hört wir hören jetzt gerade wir
reden auch beide gerade darüber dass man
sagt diese Länder sollen auf Augenhöhe
eingebunden werden andererseits würden
wir aber die lassen sich von uns nichts
mehr vorschreiben aus einem Land das man
früher Entwicklungsland genannt hätte
sagt einer den schönen Satz von China
kriegen wir einen Flughafen was wir von
den USA bekommen ist ein Vortrag kann
man den Menschen dort verdenken dass sie
über den Flughafen wollen
also erstens müssen wir diesen Ländern
sagen es ist eure Entscheidung aber wir
sagen Ihnen auch wir wollen euch nicht
den Abhängigkeit bringen die Strategie
Chinas ist es diese Länder systematisch
in Abhängigkeiten zu bringen in
wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit zu bringen
um sie außenpolitisch auszunutzen wir
sind an der Entwicklung dieser Länder
interessiert und wir müssen uns mehr
kümmern ja wir sind spät das macht unser
Angebot eben nicht oder oder macht unser
Angebot schwieriger wenn wir früher
gekommen wären wäre es besser gewesen
aber es heißt deshalb müssen das
trotzdem jetzt machen wir müssen es
besser machen ich glaube wir haben mehr
zu bieten als China die Menschen fliehen
auch nicht nach China sie fliegen in die
westlichen Freien gesellschaftschaften
und diese wollen wir in ihrer Freiheit
verteidigen und für die Prinzipien der
Freiheit die anderen Länder gewinnen auf
Augenhöhe in Partnerschaft diese Länder
sollen sich entwickeln wir wollen ihn
dabei Unterstützung geben jetzt sehen
wir aber auch dass die Position gerade
der USA eben nicht mehr die ist die sie
lange Zeit war wir Europäer schielen
allerdings immer noch Richtung USA wie
gut sind wir denn aufgestellt für den
Fall dass es Trump 2 geben sollte oder
allgemeiner gesprochen für ein weißes
Haus aus dem ein anderer Wind wehen
könnte als bei beiden derzeit
das weiß daraufhin wo eigentlich die
Hausaufgaben sind wir sind gar nicht gut
aufgestellt man könnte auch sagen gar
nicht aufgestellt obwohl die Uhr tickt
das Trump der Kandidat wird ist
wahrscheinlich der Republikaner ob er
gewählt wird ist nicht dass er gewählt
wird ist nicht auszuschließen wenn er
gewählt würde würde es nicht bei der
kooperativen Unterstützung des jetzigen
Präsidenten und der Administration
bleiben aber wir bereiten uns darauf
nicht vor und das ist das Verhalten der
Europäer was ein Ende haben wir haben
quer in Europa ein führungsmarkt um wir
begeben uns immer noch unter den Schutz
der Amerikaner die Amerikaner sind die
europäische Sicherheitswacht das muss
unser Selbstverständnis werden dazu
braucht es politische Führung in Europa
und die Uhr tickt wenn Trump gewählt
wird läuft sie sehr schnell ab das sind
anderthalb Jahre aber auch wenn beiden
gewählt wird wird er nicht dauerhaft
dieses Engagement aufrecht erhalten
können also wir müssen mit den anderen
in der Welt reden aber wir müssen um
unser Europa uns auch selber kümmern in
eigener Verantwortung das braucht eigene
Führung im Moment nicht da ist in keiner
Hauptstadt ausgeführt in Europa und die
Führung müsste von wem kommen aus Paris
aus Berlin aus Brüssel
sie muss von Deutschland ist dabei
unverzichtbar ohne Deutschland allein
wird gar nichts machen können aber ohne
Deutschland wird kein einziges Problem
gelöst der französische Präsident hat
sich leider durch ein extrem unglücklich
unglückliches Interview Interview in auf
seiner Rückreise von Peking sehr selbst
beschädigt und trotzdem ist Frankreich
zwingend immer mit an Bord wir müssen
auch Polen mit Antwort bekommen auch die
Osteuropäer wir dürfen Europa nicht
spalten aber es ist völlig klar
Deutschland als die größte
Volkswirtschaft mit dem größten Kapital
als das Land das Ost und lässt
überbrücken kann muss diese
Führungsrolle annehmen wie es alle von
Deutschland erwarten aber Deutschland
und der Bundeskanzler ist dazu exakt
nicht bereit sondern zögernd und eine
Führungsrolle nicht annehmend noch nicht
einmal kommunikativ geschweige denn
operativ also Lob für den Kanzler haben
wir jetzt von ihnen gehört und auch
Kritik am Kanzler zuletzt Norbert
Röttgen CDU aussenpolitiker herzlichen
Dank für das Gespräch heute abend ich
danke Ihnen sehr und dann lässt den
Kanzler natürlich auch auf der anderen
Seite der Erde die deutsche Innenpolitik
nicht los GEG Gebäude Energiegesetz die
Sache also mit Robert Habeck und den
Heizungen betrifft einerseits so
ziemlich jede und jeden in Deutschland
und ist andererseits alles andere als
geregelt in seiner Regierungskoalition
wird das Gesetz heftig hin und her
diskutiert und was sagt jetzt der
Kanzler heute im ZDF-Interview wie
egal wie weit man fährt man nimmt sich
und seine Probleme immer mit auch wenn
man Bundeskanzler ist
8.700 Kilometer sind es von Berlin nach
Hiroshima und Olaf Scholz verfolgt ein
Thema hochtrabend gestartet als Gebäude
Energiegesetz der Koalition wird es für
Scholz und seine Ampel jetzt zunehmend
zur Schlacht um den deutschen
Heizungskeller jetzt wird das im
Bundestag diskutiert da gilt ja der
Grundsatz eines früheren
SPD-Fraktionsvorsitzenden keinen Gesetz
kommt so aus dem Bundestag raus wie es
da reingegangen ist und das ist in der
Demokratie auch richtig ich glaube
allerdings dass es nicht dazu kommt dass
jetzt im Kern große Veränderung
vorgenommen werden das ist höhere für
Sie das Gesetz wird verändert nur nicht
im Kern die Frage ist nur was war noch
mal der Kern im April hatte das Kabinett
sich auf das heizungsgesetz verständigt
die FDP gab danach zu Protokoll nicht
mit allem einverstanden zu sein seitdem
wird gestritten jetzt hängt der
Gesetzentwurf hier zwischen den und
Fraktionen fest hier müsste er beraten
werden stattdessen Krach um Förderquoten
Altersgrenzen und ums große Ganze ein
großer Teil der deutschen Bevölkerung
macht sich Sorgen über die aktuelle
Version des Gebäude Energiegesetz laut
Umfragen sagen 75% der Menschen dass
dieses Gesetz so nicht kommen kann
deswegen ist ganz klar es bedarf
grundsätzlicher Veränderung wir brauchen
auch keine weitere Ausrede auch keine
Verzögerungstaktik warum die Menschen
brauchen jetzt Sicherheit die müssen
wissen was kommt müssen sich darauf
einstellen können und auch es muss ein
Ende der Verunsicherung geben viele
Leute haben ja das Gefühl was passiert
mir da eigentlich ich glaube wenn das
Gesetz erstmal beschlossen ist dann
wissen alle doch da wollen wir dabei
sein da können wir dabei sein und wir
werden es uns leisten können es wird im
Gegenteil sogar gut für uns sein
Finanzminister Lindner hält sich
öffentlich zurück lässt Fachpolitiker
aus der FDP sprechen ganz so als ginge
es nur um die Sache Lindner wartet
wittert die Schwäche der Grünen in
diesen Tagen die Grünen wittern die
Gefahr und beharren auf dem was mal
erkämpft war
diese verschiedenen Regeln kann man sich
sicherlich genau noch mal anschauen und
noch mal genau justieren und schauen ob
man das noch klüger und besser machen
kann es ist ja immer gut wenn Sachen
klüger und besser gemacht werden aber es
sollte nicht damit verwechselt werden
und auch kein Rückfall gegenüber den
kollisionsausschuss hergestellt werden
der sagt wir trauen ist da doch nicht
dran das wäre dann sozusagen nicht mehr
entlang der Vereinbarung
vereinbart ist das Gebäude Energiegesetz
im Koalitionsvertrag wenn es noch zum
ersten Januar 2024 kommen soll müsste
die Ampel sich zügig verständigen auf
den Kern des Gesetzes und der Koalition
Griechenland ist für viele Deutsche ein
einziger Urlaubstraum in blau und weiß
das gilt bereits an Land vom Wasser mit
seinen Abermillionen türkis
Schattierungen habe ich noch gar nicht
gesprochen allein deshalb sollten wir
uns für die Parlamentswahlen dort heute
interessieren und dazu kommen ja noch
einige Fragezeichen was den politischen
Kurs in Athen für die Zukunft angeht
Andreas Postel beobachtet die Auszählung
hallo Andreas Machtwechsel weiter wie
bisher oder Hängepartie wonach sieht es
denn jetzt aus
ja Christian es sind 80 Prozent der
Stimmen ausgezählt und danach ist
kiriakas mit so Tag ist der Amtsträger
hier der Ministerpräsident der
konservativen der Demokratia eindeutig
der Wahlsieger er hat sogar sein
Wahlergebnis von vor 4 Jahren
übertroffen und er kann trotzdem nicht
alleine weiter regieren wie er dass die
vergangenen vier Jahre getan hat weil
ich das alte Wahlgesetz von damals gilt
sondern ein neues einfaches
Verhältniswahlrecht und der deshalb
einen Koalitionsbruch Partner bräuchte
in der momentan nicht hat deswegen will
er einen zweiten Wahlgang vermutlich
anstreben Ende Juni weil er dann wieder
zurückkehren kann zum alten Wahlrecht
und dann hätte er 20 bis 50 zusätzliche
Sitze hier hinter mir im
Parlamentsgebäude um dann eine allein
Regierung vorzuführen und seinen Reform
kurz vorzuführen hier in Griechenland
nach schwierigen Jahren in Griechenland
erinnern uns ja allerdings zuletzt
wirtschaftlich aufwärts im Land sind das
auch oder ist das auch ein Grund für das
Ergebnis heute
ja also wenn man davon absieht dass 56
Prozent der Griechen gewählt haben viele
zu Hause geblieben sind und man nicht
weiß warum das sind viele Gründe die
dafür sprechen kann dann ist es aber so
die die gewählt haben bei denen haben
viele gesagt dass sie mit zur Tageskurs
sie überzeugt hat der Kurs der
Stabilisierung nach diesen schwierigen
Zeiten der Staatsschuldenkrise nach der
corona-pandemie nach den Energiekrise
und der Inflation hat es mir zur Tages
geschafft tatsächlich das Griechenland
ein Bruttoinlandsprodukt hatte was
deutlich über dem LAG des EU
Durchschnitt ist er hat die
Arbeitslosigkeit fast halbiert er hatte
die Renten erhöht erstmals seit sieben
Jahren und er hat sogar den Mindestlohn
angehoben also all das waren Maßnahmen
die ergriffen hat ein Kurs der
Stabilität und er hat eines geschafft er
hat den Griechen nur wieder stolz auf
internationaler Bühne verschafft das
haben sie ihm sehr hoch angerechnet und
der zweite Grund ist dass die
Oppositionspartei von Alexis zypress
nicht punkten konnte mit all dem was ein
Kritik in den letzten Jahren auch an
mich total ist
und deswegen hat insgesamt
offensichtlich die griechische
Wählerschaft gezeigt dass sie mich zu
Tag ist mehr Vertrauen als der
Opposition Andreas Posten war das
herzlichen Dank
so und was heute noch wichtig ist im
Überblick jetzt bei dir einer im Sudan
haben sich die Armee und die
paramilitärische Miliz RSF auf eine W
Affen ruft diese soll morgen Abend
beginnen und für sieben Tage gelten das
erklärten die USA und Saudi-Arabien die
zwischen den Konfliktparteien vermittelt
hatten durch das Abkommen soll unter
anderem humanitäre Hilfe ermöglicht
werden bisherige Feuerpausen waren von
den Kriegsparteien nicht eingehalten
worden seit Mitte April liefern sich
beide Seiten heftige Gefechte hunderte
Menschen wurden dabei getötet
hunderttausende befinden sich auf der
Flucht
nach den Überschwemmungen in Norditalien
mit mindestens 14 Toten wird das Ausmaß
der Schäden immer deutlicher am
Nachmittag machte sich
Ministerpräsidentin Meloni ein Bild der
Lage und sicherte den Betroffenen in der
Region Emilia Romania Hilfe zu die
Alarmstufe Rot wurde ein weiteres Mal
verlängert experten warnen vor neuen
Erdrutschen
in der Republik Moldau sind rund 75.000
Menschen auf die Straße gegangen um sich
für einen Beitritt in die Europäische
Union auszusprechen zu der
Großkundgebung hatte die Präsidentin des
Landes sandu aufgerufen sie erklärte
moldawia sein Europäer und Moldau wolle
nicht länger Opfer der Erpressung durch
den Kreml sein die Kundgebung ist auch
eine Reaktion auf die regelmäßigen pro
russischen Proteste in der
exoviertrepublik juni 2022 wurde Moldau
zum EU-Beitrittskandidaten
in El Salvador sind bei einer
Massenpanik in einem Fußballstadion
mindestens zwölf Menschen ums Leben
gekommen hunderte wurden verletzt und in
Krankenhäuser eingegeliefert an einem
Eingangstor war es offenbar zu einem
dichten Gedränge und dann zu der
Massenpanik gekommen
Salvadors Präsident kündigte eine
lückenlose Aufklärung des Vorfalls an
es war eine besonders dunkle Woche in
ohnehin schwarzen Zeiten für alle die
gegen Zwang Unterdrückung und im Grunde
das gesamte System des mularregimes im
Iran protestieren
iranzjustiz hat drei weitere
Demonstranten hinrichten lassen
Menschenrechtsorganisationen beklagen in
den letzten fünf Monaten bereits 220
Exekutionen in dem Land nur in China
würden jedes Jahr mehr Menschen
hingerichtet als im Iran das Ziel ein
Klima der Angst schaffen Kamera safarian
hat Regierungskritiker getroffen denen
die Flucht gelangen
in letzter Minute konnte er aus dem Iran
fliehen und lebt jetzt in Deutschland
erfahren 24 Jahre alt iranische
Sicherheitskräfte sind ihm auf den
Fersen November 2022 erfahren
protestiert in seiner Heimatstadt
dann fallen Schüsse
erfahren wird gezielt auf die Augen
geschossen mit rotkugeln bis heute lebt
der mit Schmerzen erzählt er uns
ich wurde von 25
stecken davon noch in meinem Körper in
meinem rechten Auge in meinem Kiefer in
der Hand in der Brust und im Hals
Bilder unmittelbar nach dem Anschlag
erfahren wird notdürftig privat versorgt
die revolutionsgarten haben
Krankenhäusern jegliche Hilfsdienste
untersagt immer noch steckt eine Kugel
in seinem rechten Auge erklärt er von
seinem Betreuer von den Malteser in
Mainz wenn man die Kugel herausoperiert
droht er zu erblinden sagte
erfahren ist kein Einzelfall auch Milad
hat den Karat spartera an demonstriert
auch ihm wurde in die Augen geschossen
von den 70 Schrotkugeln trafen viele
meine Hand und meinen Körper nur wenige
mein Auge sonst wäre es ganz geplatzt
blind zu werden erzeugt große Angst das
Regime will die Menschen einschüchtern
auch deswegen sind die Proteste abgeerbt
die Menschen suchen inzwischen andere
Form des Protestes und das Regime schürt
weiter Angst erst am Freitag wurden drei
Männer hingerichtet unter Folter geben
sie zu diese Sicherheitskräfte getötet
zu haben nachprüfen können wir das nicht
es gibt seit vielen Wochen bereits eine
exekutionswelle in der Islamischen
Republik laut UN wurden mindestens 200
Menschen bereits hingerichtet die
Dunkelziffer ist wohl viel höher das
Regime versucht nicht nur abzuschrecken
sondern auch zu bestrafen all jene die
gegen die islamische Republik auf die
Straße gegangen sind auch dem in den
Iran entführten Deutsch iranischen
Staatsbürger und Regimekritiker Jamie
des Schorn macht droht die Hinrichtung
seine Tochter fordert erneut Hilfe von
der Bundesregierung muss jetzt ein kr
geben der sich mit den Geiselnahmen
beschäftigt der sich mit den Europäern
beschäftigt der sich damit beschäftigt
was warum das Massen Hinrichtung ist der
sich mit Druck einsetzt um diesen Regime
zu zeigen dass es unsere rote Linie ihr
könnt nicht so weitermachen
Milad sind durch ihre Flucht eine
möglichen Todesstrafe zuvorgekommen
jetzt haben sie politisches Asyl
beantragt doch langfristig wollen sie
zurück
weil sie mich in Iran verhaften und
umbringen wollten ich war gezwungen
hierherzukommen mein Ziel ist es den
Iran zu befreien ich will die Stimme
meines Volkes sein damit unsere
Revolution erfolgreich wird wenn der
Iran befreit ist werde ich auf jeden
Fall in meiner Heimat zurückkehren
erfahrene Gegner die ihr Leben riskiert
haben und die wollen dass das Schicksal
der Menschen in Iran nicht in
Vergessenheit gerät
wir müssen weiter berichten wir werden
weiter berichten
so jetzt machen wir einen Schnitt hier
in der Sendung und du kommst noch mal
mit Sport Hannah ja und mit einer
Meldung von der Fußball-Bundesliga die
alle Fans des BVB jubeln lässt borussia
Dortmund hat Bayern überholt und ist
einen Spieltag vor Saisonende neuer
Tabellenführer dank eines drei zu null
Siegs gegen den FC Augsburg außerdem hat
der VfB Stuttgart nach dem Spiel gegen
Mainz 05 die Abstiegszone verlassen hier
der entstand 1 zu 4 und ein
Unentschieden gab es bei Bayer
Leverkusen und Borussia Mönchengladbach
mit zwei zu zwei bei der Eishockey WM
feiert das deutsche Nationalteam den
dritten Sieg in Folge und kann weiter
auf den Einzug ins Viertelfinale hoffen
das Spiel gegen Außenseiter Ungarn wurde
nach einigen Startschwierigkeiten doch
noch zum Schützenfest entstand sieben zu
zwei am Dienstag trifft die Mannschaft
von Bundestrainer Kreis dann auf
Frankreich ihren letzten Gegner in der
Vorrunde
bei den Europameisterschaften der
Rhythmischen Sportgymnastik in Baku hat
da ja war follomäf heute ihr erstes
EM-Gold geholt zuvor im Mehrkampf als
Vierte knapp die Medaille verpasst holte
sich die 16-jährige im Finale mit dem
Band und
32,25 Punkten den Sieg die Gymnasiastin
aus schmieden hatte 2022 bereits WM Gold
mit den Keulen gewonnen
so als es klar an dieser Stelle die neue
Woche kommt und wir sagen Ihnen jetzt
was sie bringen wird hier ist der heute
journal Ausblick von Franziska feske
[Musik]
wie kann der jährliche Sommerurlaub
umweltfreundlich werden und dabei
bezahlbar bleiben darüber wollen am
Montag Vertreter der Tourismusbranche
mit der Politik diskutieren auf dem
jährlichen Tourismusgipfel in Berlin
neben Nachhaltigkeit soll das auch um
den Fachkräftemangel und die
Digitalisierung gehen unter anderem
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck wird zu Gast
sein
am Dienstag werden die deutschen
Fußballclubs über einen möglichen
Investoren Einstieg in den deutschen
Profifußball entscheiden auf einer
Mitgliederversammlung wird die Deutsche
Fußball Liga die Bewerber vorstellen was
bei vielen Fans auf Protest stößt soll
die DFL konkurrenzfähiger machen zwei
Milliarden Euro sollen einmalig fließen
im Gegenzug gibt es Anteile an den
TV-Einnahmen Laufzeit 20 Jahre Stimmen
Zweidrittel der Clubs zu soll bis Ende
September ein Vertrag stehen
am Sonntag wird in der Türkei wieder
gewählt Präsident Erdogan und seinen
Herausforderer Kilic tarolu treten in
der Stichwahl gegeneinander an beide
hatten in der ersten Runde die 50
Prozentmarke verfehlt dieses Mal reicht
eine einfache Mehrheit fürs
Präsidentenamt dafür entscheiden könnte
auch die Wahlempfehlung von Sinan Ohren
sein der als Drittplatzierter gut 5% der
Wählerstimmen holte
und so wird das Wetter in den kommenden
Tagen morgen im Osten und Südosten viel
Sonne sonst von Westen her aufkommende
Schauer und Gewitter Lokal Unwetter
durch Starkregen und Hagel Höchstwerte
21 bis 29 Grad am Dienstag bei 15 bis 24
Grad weitere teils kühler
und damit sagen wir zwei im Namen des
gesamten Teams auch der Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hinter den Kameras danke für
Ihr Interesse morgen freuen sich hier
Maria Slomka und Hans Wolf auf sie und
die nächsten Nachrichten gibt's hier
gegen 0.25
[Musik]